Welcome to "Ear Biscuits".
The podcast where two friends, lifelong.
Oh gosh.
Talk about life
for a long time.
I left that word out
but I put it in later.
I'm Link.
Wow and I'm really
wanting you to do it again
but I'm not going to
enforce that, I'm Rhett.
This week at The Roundtable.
You're my friend,
lifelong man.
This week at The
Roundtable of Dim Lighting
we are picking up
on our friendship
through the years series.
This time we are talking about
the high school versions of us
and specifically the high school
version of our friendship.
Because as we were just
talking about a second ago
we you know, let's be honest.
We're two friends, comma, lifelong comma.
Yeah, I'm with you.
Talking about life
for a long time.
We end up treading through
some of the same ground.
Like we've talked about the
way that we were engaging,
each of us were engaging
with our sexuality
through the years
in high school.
Sure.
We've talked about how we
engaged with our spirituality
and now we're kind of honing in on the.
How we've engaged with each other.
Yeah yeah.
And not sexually or
spiritually necessarily
but just as friends.
And so.
Lifelong.
We might be revisiting
some of the same territory
but hopefully bringing
some new perspective to it
and also you did bring
some yearbooks I see.
Yeah, I ask you to bring yearbooks
but it was this morning.
I mean it was 7 a.m..
I believe.
I thought you had plenty of
time to find your yearbooks.
Well I'm not gonna, I did look.
I have a section.
I should've told you
a week ago.
I have a section
in my garage that is in
need of reorganization.
That is, those Rubbermaid
boxes and they're three deep.
And two or three high.
Oh God, yeah.
And it's up on this thing
that I had to get on top
of a ladder and stand.
I literally have to stand,
I did it this morning
and I feel, I feel bad about this.
This is like a six-foot stepladder
and in order to get to the top box,
I am standing totally
on top of the ladder.
Do not do that.
Like on the green part
at the top.
That you're not,
you're not even supposed to put a foot.
I'm putting both feet on that.
My business is
too tied to yours.
Like economically we are too tied together
for you to be teetering
on top of a ladder.
I have excellent balance
for a tall person though.
You're 12 foot seven inches
above the garage floor,
the concrete floor.
I thought about asking my
wife to hold the ladder
but that would've required
coming back down the ladder,
going up to the stairs to the house.
The top two steps of a
ladder are not steps.
Yeah, yeah I'm ashamed.
I'm ashamed.
They're to be leaned on.
And you still came down
with nothing.
And I still didn't find
any of your books.
You have nothing
to show for it.
'Cause I think they're in
the way back.
Can I ask you something totally unrelated
before we get into this based on something
that happened to this morning?
It's very fresh.
I love,
I love changing subjects.
When you go to the bathroom,
here at the office,
we're still wearing masks in here.
It's the utmost protection for everybody.
Protection.
In our studio.
So we're still in mask mode indoors
as people are working.
When you go to the bathroom.
I take my mask off, is that
what you're about to ask me?
And do you take your mask off?
No.
When you,
if you poop in the bathroom,
do you take your mask off?
I mean.
Yes or no?
No, why would I?
So I could smell it more?
Well, I.
That's one of the benefits of,
I've actually, I hate wearing a mask.
I've established this
with my beard, I hate it.
I have to comb the beard out.
But when I go to the bathroom,
I actually think to myself,
"This is one scenario where it really."
'Cause even when you're
thinking about a virus,
it's not tangible and
sometimes you're like,
ah man is this really doing anything?
But when I'm in the bathroom
and I'm pooping, I'm like,
"This mask is doing things for me."
And also doing things for me,
to not have to think about
who was in here before me
and what particles they left in here.
If what I'm about to tell
you changes your mind,
proceed with caution.
I have no idea where this is going
but it must be that you don't
wear a mask in the bathroom.
Yeah, I.
Well I don't like to wear
a mask in the bathroom
when I'm pooping because.
You poop through your mouth.
I don't.
It's a.
Boy that's hilarious.
No, I don't poop through my mouth.
You jerk.
Well, okay.
It was a joke.
But I do believe that actually
is a thing that can happen,
poop through the mouth.
I don't want to talk about that.
It's probably on WebMD.
I take my mask off when
I'm pooping in the bathroom
because I don't want to suck in.
I don't want all this poop
stuff to get caught in my mask
that then for the rest of the
day I am slowly breathing in
poopy particles.
You're not breathing it in.
It's on the outside of the mask.
It's in the mask
and then some of it gets through the mask.
Yeah, where have you read this?
What research paper?
I haven't read it anywhere.
But that's what I do okay?
I'm almost sure the poop doesn't make it
through the mask.
It doesn't seem like
I'm changing your mind but, oh.
Whatever happened to Mr?
So you'd rather do?
Open-minded Rhett?
Well I mean.
Just be open minded
until I'm done with my story okay?
I'm close-minded about things
I'm right about.
Be open minded.
No, no.
Can you keep your mind open
until I'm done with my story?
Okay, there's more okay.
I haven't even told it yet.
Okay, all right.
I'm ready for more.
So I sat down to poop this
morning in the bathroom.
I sit down and then I look over
and I make sure the door is
locked and then I realize,
you know what?
I still have my mask on.
I forgot to take my mask
off and here I am pooping.
Now I don't want all these poop
particles caught in my mask.
I want my mask to be.
I'm one of those people who like yeah,
takes his mask off to sneeze
'cause I don't want sneeze
particles inside of my mask.
You sat the mask outside the bathroom?
Well exactly.
So what I normally do is I
put my mask in my back pocket
when I'm taking my mask off for stuff,
like when we're filming stuff.
So what I did was I took
my mask off and then
I instinctively started
putting it in my back pocket
and I almost wiped my ass with my mask.
Yeah, this is appropriate.
This is how ill-advised
your whole scenario is.
I never would've told you that yeah,
I am on the brink of wiping my own ass
with my mask.
Well I -
But I was.
I guarantee you.
Here I was.
This has happened
with hundreds if not thousands of people.
Not by accident.
That makes me feel better.
Because think about it.
Oh, when you run out
of toilet paper?
How many people have
run out of toilet paper
and up to this point in time,
most of us didn't have on masks.
Now you've got an ass mask.
And people are like,
"Well I'm gonna go into
the bathroom with a mask
"and come out without one
and have to explain this."
I mean there was TP in
there but let me tell you,
I came a lot closer than I want to admit.
Do you still have this mask?
Yes, in my back pocket.
So how close did it get to your butt hole?
I don't know, just can you, just tell.
Just sniff it.
Just sniff it man.
But see here's the problem.
Here's the problem.
Didn't you watch that?
I love how you didn't even want to say no.
You just sniffed it.
I'm not going to sniff it.
Sniff it.
Mike Rowe had this,
I want to do some podcasts they do this.
Have you noticed that?
Where they like just sit here
with the microphone like this.
In fact I'm gonna start doing it.
I didn't actually wipe
my ass with my mask.
That's why I'm still
using it and it's fresher.
Would you like me to tell you,
or I can also tell me 'cause I'm here
why your plan is wrong?
Nope, that's not what this is about.
Okay.
I think, I think.
Well then why'd you tell me about it?
If you don't think that it's obvious,
then it doesn't need to be explained.
Well I think maybe even.
I think it's obvious.
More important.
I almost wiped my ass
with a mask.
It's obvious why that was a bad idea.
But I also think.
I don't need you to tell me.
This is a violation of our work protocol.
As the co-owner of our company.
Oh.
I didn't want to discuss
company policy in this scenario
but I will say that the.
There's a vent.
Yeah but in the bathroom when
you've got your pants down,
you're breathing hard and
you're in an enclosed space
that someone else is about to come into,
this is probably one of the top spaces
that you should keep your mask on.
And you're taking your mask off
and almost wiping your ass with it?
Not anymore man.
And you're like.
Not anymore.
You own half
of this company.
I'll tell you man.
We need to adjust
the percentages.
All of this mask thing,
it's so fresh to me you know?
What is it?
It's very old to me.
I haven't quite got,
I haven't quite got the hang
of this whole mask thing yet.
I think it's picking up steam though.
People wearing masks.
The only way that your plan
would make sense is if before,
just from a personal hygiene standpoint.
Not from a company policy
'cause we've already established
that you violated that.
I don't have COVID.
You sound like,
you sound like such an idiot.
No I've taken two tests already today.
Yeah, yeah well I understand that.
But the only way that
your plan makes sense
is if you were to take your mask.
When I wipe my ass with my mask.
Let me finish, damn it.
I didn't sound like
an idiot?
I just don't like it when you
tell me I sound like an idiot
when it's obvious I sound like an idiot.
Oh I'm just, this is for the folks.
Don't state the obvious.
This is for the folks
at home if he's not gonna listen to me.
The only way this makes
sense is to take your mask,
put it in your back pocket
before you go into the bathroom
which by the way, would be a
violation of company policy
and if you do it outside,
everyone would see you do it.
So it would be setting, not only that,
it would be setting a bad example.
Then you go into the
bathroom, do your business
and then come out.
That's the only way to follow your logic
which is to not get poop on your mask.
Yeah.
But you're the guy who's
trying to wipe his ass
with this mask.
So apparently poop on the mask
is not something that you've,
not having poop on the mask
is not something you value.
It's a very ironic, what happened.
Obviously what should happen
is after I'm done pooping,
without ever taking my mask off,
I should then put on a fresh
mask as I exit the restroom.
That's what I'm gonna do from
now on, everybody's happy.
Yeah, you figured it out.
We didn't even need to
have this discussion.
Let's promote our podcast.
Well you know, we actually
have a Mythical Pods
TikTok account because we
have found that you know,
sometimes things are said on this podcast
and the other three podcasts that we have.
"A Hot Dog Is a Sandwich",
"Best Friends Back, Alright!"
and "Trevor Talks Too Much".
Yeah.
All the Mythical pods, things are said
that are interesting and you might be one,
just to get a little tidbit of a podcast.
And that works really well on TikTok.
Just a little.
Just a little dingleberry.
If you want a dingleberry of a podcast,
any of our Mythical podcasts.
Follow the @mythicalpods TikTok channel.
If you're just not on TikTok
because you've you know,
you're like, ah that's one more platform
I don't want to get on.
Well.
Get over that.
We'll see you soon.
Get over that, please.
I mean, I'm just telling
you, this is your sign.
You know how, when people
say that this is your sign.
Get on TikTok.
My recommendation today
is gonna be TikTok.
So over the course of listening
to the rest of this podcast,
I'm gonna recommend a TikTok
account so you'll be ready,
it'll be one of the first
ones you can follow.
And I'll add to that.
So now we're just promoting TikTok.
Well unfortunately, I don't
remember the guy's name
but there was a guy who
made a YouTube video
and I think you can look this up.
It didn't have very many
views when I watched it.
Like literally like three because
he had added me on Twitter
and that's why I saw it.
But the name of the video on YouTube
is "Rhett and Link are holes"
and I watched it and it was a funny video
where he's actually a big fan.
Oh.
Who has been watching
since the beginning
and has just discovered
that we have a TikTok
and that we've been doing
all these old school sketch stuff.
Like the old school Rhett and Link days.
We're holes 'cause he
didn't know about it?
I mean I kind of, I don't
know what exactly the logic
but I think that was just
more of a clickbait thing.
Okay.
So anyway, yeah.
This is no longer the ad by the way,
we're back into the show.
Right.
Because we're not,
you know we're just telling
you to follow Mythical Pods
on TikTok and we're telling
you to just get TikTok
if you're saying it's not for you
because I'm gonna recommend
something at the end all right?
And we're holes apparently
but in a good way.
Look at this photo Rhett.
Look at these photos
of us from high school.
Look at that one, describe it.
This is your bathroom
at your house.
Yeah.
We're using a flash camera
because that's covering up your face.
Almost completely, the flash.
You're in your letter jacket.
Yep.
And we are both wearing.
I was,
I was a star soccer player in high school.
We are both wearing beanies
which we would have called.
Toboggans.
Toe-baggans.
Well I didn't say
toe-baggan, I said toboggan.
You know.
That's 'cause I was born
and raised in North Carolina.
I moved.
I moved to North Carolina
at age six.
You've moved around.
And they still have
the price tags on them.
What does it say on there?
I don't know, I can't figure that out
but we bought these toboggans
and we like to take pictures of ourselves.
I took one of you.
That was a cool jacket, very warm.
And then you took one of me.
That's a flattering face.
And again, we didn't take these pictures
and then immediately look at them.
We took these pictures and then waited,
maybe months before we
could see them again
because we had to finish the
roll and then get it developed.
We could've invented Instagram back then
doing pictures like this.
Look at this, I mean look
at how much fun we had.
You and me in my room.
Get an index card.
Is that an index card?
With toboggans on.
That's a napkin with your
tongue being pressed through it
to make a hole.
I'm taking a very point
blank closeup picture of you
and then you.
Outside of the focus range
of the camera.
You thought it was such a good idea
that then you took a picture
of me doing the same thing.
And then here's one that's,
it's tough to take a selfie
when you're you know,
when you can't take a whole bunch of them.
So we were having a good time now.
Now this is.
We were such good friends.
This is senior year 'cause
you've got that jacket.
No, I got the jacket
after my freshman year.
I got my letter jacket as a freshman.
Are you 100% sure of this?
Yeah, because there was no JV soccer team.
Everybody was on the varsity
soccer team so I like.
They let you get it as a freshman?
Well I was on the varsity soccer team.
Every varsity player got a letter jacket.
Are you jealous or something?
Well yeah but I, no.
I thought that.
I'm 100% positive.
That you got it as a freshman?
Yes because.
It feels like
a little bit of a cheat code.
It didn't, I got.
Just being honest with you.
I played in one game.
A game that we won nine to zero.
I know this because in the
yearbook my mom kept the,
she kept the schedule and
she wrote down the score
and we were in the final four
of state playoffs that year.
That was the peak of soccer.
For Harnett Central High School.
When you weren't playing.
When I was on the bench.
But I got my, I got my letter jacket
and I think that's what I remember
about starting high school
and it really had an impact
on our friendship.
Because you know, we were so nervous.
We thought a lot about
beginning high school.
We were really in that head space
when we were writing "The
Lost Causes of Bleak Creek".
Because we put our experiences
into, into that story.
And there was so much expectation.
But I actually started playing soccer.
We had practice like six
weeks before classes began.
And I remember being so
nervous 'cause it's like okay,
I'm on the soccer team.
There's no tryout, everybody
makes it like I said.
But still I was nervous because okay,
you got these upper classmen.
All of a sudden I'm playing
soccer with seniors and juniors
and I don't know that many
people from Buies Creek
who are going over here
and playing soccer.
You played soccer in middle school
because everybody who
liked soccer kind of played
but then in high school you
started to just matriculate
so to speak.
So soccer for me was my
introduction to high school
and you didn't have any part of that.
And then that became a part
of my identity as a freshman,
as a soccer player.
But basketball.
I will say that.
Basketball season hadn't started.
I will say if you don't remember this
is that Coach Randall, was that his name?
Brandall.
Actively, almost to
the point of harassment
recruited me to be on the soccer team.
As the goalie?
Yes.
Because you could
stretch out.
Well because I allowed
one goal in middle school.
One goal.
I was trained by, you remember Peter.
What was his name?
He was this famous Campbell goalie
that I think is in like
the Campbell Hall of Fame
for being a goalie.
Peter something.
And my dad hired him.
Oh really?
To come and train me.
Oh wow.
And I remember being out in the cold
and having to learn how to do that thing
where you fall on your
side and then my dad got me
like the equipment.
Just lay out, yeah.
I got really good.
I could do the dropkick you know?
And I'm like six, I was already
six five going into school.
He would actively,
aggressively kind of like
try to bully me to being on the goalie.
It almost worked.
He had an abrasive personality.
I should've done it man.
The stories we could've had.
Coach Brandall was the
coolest guy but yeah,
you should've done it
man because well I mean,
you were focused on
basketball at that point.
I was like, "I gotta ready
for basketball season."
And man but yeah, Chad.
Chad Holly was a senior
and he was a really good
keeper.
He was great.
He was a great keeper.
He played, and again,
that's one of the reasons
we went to the final four.
We had a pretty good team
but he was a great keeper
and yeah he played in college.
But you would've been
groomed, sophomore year
you would've taken over.
Who ended up?
Who ended up, I Brian Coleman did,
was a goalie for awhile.
No no, he was defense.
No, yeah he was a sweeper.
He could boot it really, really far.
He also, he'd do the flip.
He could do that thing where
you're throwing in from the sideline
and you would get a running start
and he would put the ball on the ground,
do a flip and then throw it in.
Yeah, yeah yeah.
And everybody would just
be like flabbergasted on the other team
and so they would just stop playing.
Yeah, it was a great technique.
Who was your goalie?
Phillip Hatcher became the goalie,
remember him?
Oh yeah yeah
and he was good.
He was a glutton for punishment
and you kind of have to be.
He was fearless.
Yeah throwing yourself
all in the ground.
I think I was
a little bit too scared
of getting hurt also.
Yeah, you gotta throw your body around.
Ah I don't like getting hurt.
So of course I mean,
we were best friends going
into freshman year but like,
I had this reconnaissance thing.
You were on the cross country team though
and you guys started running before.
Not freshman year.
Oh you weren't?
So once classes started,
I felt like oh I'm
wearing my letter jacket.
I'm a part of something,
I'm getting in where I
fit in kind of thing.
I'm part of a team.
It actually helped kind of
kickstart things a little bit.
At least I
have to think it does.
Well my brother
was a senior.
That helped you.
And he was like a popular guy.
Was you know one of the
stars on the basketball team
and so there was this sort of,
a little bit of a runway
setup for be coming in
as another McLaughlin right?
And I don't know.
I've never, especially
at that point in my life.
I've never been one to
like get too nervous
about the next stage.
I get much more excited
about the next stage right?
And so, I remember.
There was a, before
school started that year.
There was an athlete,
some sort of athlete, I
can't remember what it was.
But it was the first
event at Harnett Central
before school started.
Orgy?
Yeah it was an orgy, outside.
In the tobacco pit where everybody smoked.
No, it was just some sort of get together
and my brother was going
and I was gonna go with him
and I just remember thinking a lot about
what I was gonna wear
and I wore these shorts.
And of course I tucked
a polo shirt into them.
Braided belt?
And I had a braided belt
that went.
Hell yeah.
Boy, it got close to the knee.
Got close to the knee.
Tied into that knot
and send it south.
And no shoes.
I mean no socks.
It was very phallic.
And loafers.
Penny loafers with no socks, wow.
But you blended in with that,
instead of being very tall and lanky.
And I was so tan.
You know that like?
Sunscreen, we didn't
understand that that was a.
Didn't believe in it.
We didn't think that was
a thing that you could do.
It was like you don't need sunscreen
unless you have red hair
and I don't have red hair.
When you get a tan
that becomes your sunscreen.
Your sunscreen.
Is what we thought.
And by the end of the
summer, boy you were tan.
Oh yeah.
You know and you'd show up,
I just remember walking into that setting
with just so much confidence.
Oh you had confidence?
Well I mean you know.
Yeah, I didn't
have confidence.
Going in.
Going in as a freshman, six five.
You know you're looking down on everybody.
You got a brother who's
already paved the way.
You know a lot of people
who are gonna be there.
You know what I'm saying?
You're good, you're not going,
you're bringing everyone from your school
'cause we were going.
Buies Creek joined Lillington
and Angier all together
and Lafayette.
And Layfayette.
All together.
So that's still
the minority.
And that's how I looked at you know?
No I was like, we've got a faction man.
We're at least a quarter of the school.
A quarter of the population
is a minority Rhett.
Yeah that was enough though.
But I mean, yeah and it was like,
and then all these upper classmen
from all of these other places too.
You didn't know them.
You really didn't know
a lot of the older Buies Creek people too.
So I mean it was definitely
an exciting time.
I remember there was no commons area
in our elementary slash middle school.
You know where there was that break
and everybody would like,
like hum ha around and fiddlefart around.
After homeroom.
So me being on the soccer team,
you were focused on basketball
and then the basketball season started.
I don't know, after a
couple of months I guess.
October.
I mean that was.
That was a big separation
for us that started to,
you know we had identities
apart from one another
in ways that kind of like
could get a little cliqueish right?
So and I think that was the
first time we experienced that
as friends.
What we discussed before from
middle school, it was more,
it was more like, well you
lived on that side of town.
So you had your friends
and I was on the other side of town alone.
Now it was more of, okay
I've got my soccer team,
I've got some friends there.
You know, I made friends
with Jason from Angier
and he would invite me to
his house and I was like,
"Okay, I'm hanging out with other people."
So our horizons were expanding
and our friend group hadn't yet coalesced
beyond what it would become
in sophomore junior year.
We started to develop a friend group
with some Lillington
people, some Angier people
and a lot of Buies Creek people
and we had a pretty tight group
there for a couple of years.
But I remember freshman year it was,
it was kind of this branching out.
I didn't really, I didn't, that is true
but I didn't see it that way.
Yeah, it's not something
we ever talked about.
Because I think.
It's more in retrospect.
I had definitely had this again,
we talked about it.
That summer between eighth
and ninth grade and you know,
going and swimming in the
river and this is when we had,
at that point definitely
our friendship with Ben
had really transformed.
So that summer going to the river
was something that was
pretty much me and you.
We still hung out with
Ben when he felt up to it
but he didn't,
there was a lot of times
when he didn't feel up to it
and making that phone call
and seeing if he was feeling okay,
it just created this thing that
me and you became this unit.
So.
Yeah.
We talked about what we
were going to experience
and what we were going to do
and of course I was talking a lot about
all the women that were
gonna be here at this place.
If there's a thousand people,
we're going to this place
that's got that many more women
and I saw us as this unit that,
I kind of just took that for granted.
That like okay well,
I'm not going to try to
find another best friend
or anything you know?
It's like.
And I never, I did.
I was never threatened.
I didn't think there was anything
that was all gonna fall
apart at this point.
Yeah we were getting,
we were definitely
getting closer than ever
but it was the first
time that we had aspects
of our high school identity
that were completely separate.
Like you as a basketball player right?
Yeah I mean, there was
a little bit of that
in middle school.
But it began to develop more.
But I was friends with everybody
on the basketball team.
Like in high school I
wasn't friends with anybody
on the basketball team.
Yeah that's true.
Because it's all new students
and there's a lot more of them.
So you know the ones that
you're kind of hanging out with.
Yeah I mean the thing, I
started to experience this.
Now I kind of understand it
as the chameleon-like quality
of an Enneagram 3 that I never
really understood was a thing
until it started looking like
in personality evaluations.
But that's a tendency
to sort of infiltrate a particular group
and be a version of yourself in that group
in order to excel in that group.
So there was sort of a
basketball version of me right
which is a totally
different set of friends
'cause they're all on the basketball team
and a kind of different way of being.
Like that version of
Rhett was pretty serious
and committed and worried
about being good at basketball
and kind of thought he was pretty cool
because it wasn't a silly environment.
Did you have locker room slang?
I don't remember that but maybe.
You were like, "Boy I'm
flaming some hoops tonight."
But you know how,
you get into a certain environment where,
and the basketball team
is different than the soccer team right?
Because the basketball team is way smaller
than the soccer team
or way smaller than the football team.
There is this sense
that you're like.
yeah.
Hey, we're the 12 guys that
they chose for this right?
There's just this sense
that like you're kind of in
this elite group of guys.
And guys especially sort
of like embrace that
and kind of start to
feel like this cool gang.
You would wear your
uniform to class on the day
you were playing right?
No no, you wore a suit.
Oh that's right, you
wore a suit to school.
You had to wear a suit and tie.
That was the rule.
You had to wear a suit
and tie on game day.
Oh wow.
Yeah.
That's wild.
Yeah and that was really
once we were on varsity which for me,
started sophomore year.
Oh okay.
But the point I'm making
is that there's this mode.
There's sort of a social code
amongst the basketball team
where I'm behaving in a different way
and as soon as I'm outside
of that environment,
I'm not that guy anymore.
I am silly, class clown Rhett.
Yeah.
You know which is
what I was most of the time
and then of course with you,
we were, it was a whole
different level of silliness.
Taking selfies with beanies on.
I guess I want to emphasize.
Yeah.
The embarrassing level of
silliness that we were still.
I mean we never really stopped but.
Yeah.
It was just,
it was so, so stupid.
We acted so stupid.
It was fun man.
Oh yeah.
I mean, when I read through.
Once I started looking at these yearbooks
and I started reading
everybody's notes, that was.
It helped put things back in perspective.
First of all, we went to Trinidad
after our freshman year of high
school on that mission trip
because all of our friends,
all of our church friends
were talking about we were going.
The school year had ended and
this was like the big thing,
we're going to Trinidad.
So that's when that happened.
But every single person called me crazy.
Like I was, I guess I was.
I'm pleasantly surprised and
I'm sure the same goes for you
because people would write about me
and people would write about us
and then our closest friends
like Michael and Trent,
they would write about me and you.
You know it's like, we
were these ringleaders
amongst a group of guy
friends because we had these,
we were super silly, we were super crazy.
All the girls just thought we like had,
I'm projecting my notes onto you
because I know it's true of you too
because I just read these.
All the girls just thought
in our friend group,
just thought we were just crazy.
Thank you for making
us laugh all the time.
That type of thing.
And then there were people who
were not in our friend group
who were on the edge
who would say it a little bit differently.
Like you were the craziest
person I've ever met.
I have no clue.
It's like we were, we were just.
And it was a silliness.
It wasn't like,
it wasn't like Jackass
like Johnny Knoxville.
Like they'll, and we would
do some daring things
but it really was more
about just cutting the fool.
Like being the butt of
the joke if I had to be,
that type of thing.
Class clowns and us being a unit
that would bring other people into it.
Like people, our friend group,
the way that I can see in the yearbook
is that they all fed off of our energy
and it's just something.
Sometimes I feel like
we've developed personas,
because we have.
It was nice to go back
and like, have a 98%
agreement amongst notes
that we were that way then too you know?
We were organizing.
We've always been about
entertaining people
and so if you think about the
things that we ended up doing.
There was this, all right
we've got this group of people.
Let's figure out, let's
find a way to do something
that's a fun experience.
So something as stupid as
let's do that thing where we,
in the middle of the summer
we're gonna go to the movies
but on the way to movies at Waverly Place.
Yeah.
We're gonna turn
the heat on.
This is North Carolina,
it's 95 degrees at night.
90% humidity, let's turn
the heat all the way up
and play heavy metal music really loud.
And thrash.
And thrash
all the way to Cary.
Just to see how much you can sweat.
And then when you get
out of the car it'll,
it'll feel great.
It'll feel cool.
You'll be sweating your ass off though.
Then you'll stink in the theater.
And let's get our friends
to do that with us.
As long as we all stink together.
Let's bring more people
and we both were like that.
Love to bring people into that situation.
So I think that this career
that we found ourselves in.
It's just instinct.
Is about bringing people
along for a good time.
There's a lot of notes,
freshman year notes
about hey this summer.
Can I, maybe I can go
chase cows with you guys.
'Cause that's what we had been
doing for a couple of years.
Everybody knew that after
school, we would go back.
Your brother would bring you
home, Kevin would take me home
and then we would get on
our bikes as freshmen.
We were still doing that
middle school-type stuff
where it was like we're
going into the woods.
We're going swimming in the river.
We're gonna chase these cows
and then we're gonna
come back the next day
and we're gonna tell everybody about it
as if they missed the best thing ever.
It's like, so by the end of
the year people were like,
"Can I come?
"Maybe I can do that?"
Well we did.
The camping was later.
That was like.
Well we did eventually bring them along.
Yeah.
And we told that story about
they all ended up crying.
Yeah.
Several of them did when they
almost drowned in the river
and it was, that was a bad move.
So there was the, yeah but back to
your basketball identity thing
and my soccer identity thing.
Yeah we were starting to branch
out but at the same time,
those things like chasing
cows and spinning,
like the default being.
If it was when we weren't practicing,
I had soccer practice
every day after school.
When that was over, then it was basketball
but then we would always
find time even when like,
the reason why
we would chase cows during
basketball game days
is because you weren't
practicing after school I think
and so it was our only
opportunity to still get out there
and get back into the woods.
It was kind of like, those
people who loved to fish
and they carry around their fishing pole
and they're always waiting to like.
I see a water hole
and I'm gonna go over there and fish.
We were kind of that way about
getting back into the woods
and sophomore year you got your license.
We could do that even more.
It was closer to junior year I guess.
Or the summer after that
I got my license but.
Right.
That overwrote, that time in
the woods chasing the cows,
the fact that we were
unabashedly best friends
doing strange things.
I think, I mean that was the
backbone of our friendship
and there was this identity of okay,
there's the two of us and
are you in on it or not?
And I think that that's what,
that's what sort of
solidified our friendship
and solidified it as a unit.
Is the fact that okay, if we've got this.
If one of us has this
ridiculous idea to do something,
there's no question whether the other guys
are gonna go along with it.
Right.
So okay I know I'm in
to this.
Now let's go and try to
get other people on board
but we're bringing this
thing to our friends.
Like even with the idea to start the band,
was yeah it's like okay.
Eric gets a guitar and starts playing it
and it's like his intention
in getting a guitar
is more like,
"I want to learn how to play the guitar."
Maybe get girls.
It's like this is something
that I'm interested in doing
just personally as a hobby
that I want to explore.
And then we're immediately thinking,
"Well yeah but we need to start a band."
You know it's like.
Yeah.
It's you've got a guitar,
we are all friends.
That means we should start a band.
That just seemed like
the logical next thing.
It's like how do you blow this
idea, the seed of this idea
out into something that
is just a big experience?
And me and you didn't,
there wasn't this stopping
to convince each other.
It was all right, yeah band great idea.
Now let's convince some
other people about this.
Yeah.
That was the kind of mode
and I think that getting,
doing that without ever
having to confer about it is,
it's the reason that we
ended up working together.
And to see.
'Cause people are
always like, we forget.
Two is a majority with any idea.
But people forget, we
forget the sort of novelty
of the depth and length of our
friendship but also the fact
that oh you've been working
together for all this time.
And how does that work?
And how do, explain that to me
and it's like well because there were,
there was an unwritten language
that was being developed
and honed over many, many years.
Where there's a whole lot of other things
that normal business partners
have to have a conversation
about something.
They have to work through something.
They have to get on the
same page about something.
I'm not saying we're
always on the same page.
We're very different in some ways
and we work through things.
We have a lot of conflict
and we've talked about that in the past
but the core of it is something that
there's a lot of unspoken things.
And I think that high school,
as we sort of broke off
from the trio of the two of us and Ben,
just because of
what was happening
circumstantially with Ben.
Began to, that began to solidify.
I remember freshman year, English class.
Kelly Smith, our teacher,
she drove a Mitsubishi 3000GT.
GT.
And she, we're in the same
class but what we gave her,
we gave her hell.
But she loved us because she
thought we were ridiculous.
And we were kind of a cutup duo.
But we were very engaged
with what she was doing
and she's like.
She was super cool.
You're gonna do a speech.
And we were like, "Okay, wait.
"What we're about to break
out for this speech."
Yeah.
We're very participatory
in class.
We had a section on film.
She taught us the rule of thirds.
She taught us you know,
lots of cinematic
principles and then said,
"All right guys, you're gonna divide up."
I think it was two groups,
it might have been three.
But maybe just two.
And you're gonna make a movie.
Who here has a video camera?
And you're like, "Ah
I've got a video camera."
And Trent was like, "I
got a video camera."
And it was like,
"Okay so you guys are
on different groups."
And then she assigned the groups.
I got assigned to Trent's
group, not your group
and I was really pissed off
about that 'cause I was like,
we've already, we've been.
What a missed opportunity.
We were making videos
in middle school.
Miss Smith.
We could be showing this, we could be cut
into a video right now.
We would be so much
further along in our careers
if she had let us work together
in that class.
So I was pretty bummed out.
I don't know what your group made
but my group made a horror
movie like ala Scream
involving, let's see.
Like somebody calling from,
calling a house but then realizing
they were calling from inside the house.
Because wasn't there a thing
where you could call your
own number and make it ring?
Yeah.
Can you still do that?
I don't know, I don't have a landline.
You could call and make your,
and something about that was
like pivotal in the script
of like oh my God, he's in the house.
That sounds interesting and compelling.
I have no idea what my group did.
I think I was more of a cinematographer.
I wasn't as much into it
because it wasn't a comedy
and you and I weren't making it together.
But I do remember it being a
lot better than your group's.
So I did feel a little vindication.
Are you serious?
That like maybe, I was like,
"Maybe he needs me more than I need him."
Oh you're rewriting
history man.
I'm rewriting history.
I don't remember yours
being better though.
I'm sure.
Well I don't remember what I did
but I'm sure was.
You don't remember it at all
it wasn't memorable.
I'm sure was a comedy
because I used every
opportunity that I had to.
And I'm sure you took charge, yeah.
Because somebody has to.
I don't remember what.
You had the camera.
But yeah I mean that was pivotal.
That was a great class and it was like,
we actually started to.
That was the first time
we started thinking about,
oh there's principles
associated with filmmaking.
You know 'cause you watch movies,
it don't register with us.
So a question that I want to explore
but I know we're gonna read
something from the yearbook.
So I don't know which one.
Yeah I could.
We should do first 'cause
I want to talk about the.
Okay.
Just the aspect of future
planning stuff and that dynamic.
Well our, let's see, 1995.
So this is 1993, okay.
This will play right in to
what you wanna talk about.
First of all after freshman year,
I'm pretty sure we've
read this one before.
Like your note to me.
"Link Neal, you have 14
different things going for you."
Well hold on, you didn't read the.
I wrote something in print.
Charles Lincoln Smith
Johnson Neal the third.
Okay.
So you.
I was embellishing.
I was making fun of
how many names you had.
Yeah you have 14 different
things going for you.
Oh thank you, very complimentary.
"But I can only mention
one, you have soul.
"When I say soul,
"I'm not talking about the kind of soul
"that Veronica Swan said you had.
"I don't remember her saying
"I had soul at all or what kind it was.
"So I can't comment on that.
"But I'm talking about
the kind that run DMC."
DMC or DMC,
you just spelt it three
different ways talks about it.
I think you thought that was funny.
Like I would like, what did I do?
It was alternate spellings of DMC.
Oh and then some phonetic spellings.
Phonetic yeah.
"If you got the soul then keep the soul.
"If you ain't got the
soul, then get the soul.
"Fart blossoms only come once a year.
"So don't let them pass by you.
"If you try hard, you
can catch one in a net.
"If you don't catch one, then buy one.
"I'm sure your granddad has plenty."
My grandad Clyde, my papa.
He would always call me a fart blossom.
Right.
And you signed it Rico
and then in parentheses you put stupid.
Ah.
So it was self deprecating.
"P.S.,I wanted to do something
"that would mess up your
yearbook so look down."
And then in a big scrawl
you wrote, "Rusty Jernagan."
Which was another guy
we went to school with.
Yeah.
So that was signed
as another person very big, obnoxiously.
There was nothing meaningful in there.
There was nothing heartfelt in there.
Oh come on, there's a lot
of heartfelt stuff in that.
I mean think, if you gotta
read between the lines.
I really want you to dig up
what I wrote in your yearbook
and I'm sure it was equally stupid.
Hold on, but I mean yeah
I'm trying to crack.
It was sweet.
I'm trying to crack you up but
read between the lines man.
There was a connection there.
Okay.
There's like 14
different things you got going for you.
Yeah, well that was nice.
You've got soul, that's
the best compliment
you got in the whole yearbook probably.
Yeah, I still don't know
what you meant by it though.
I don't either, it's been awhile.
And then the fart blossoms part, I have.
That's just silliness.
Just prose.
That's just prose, it didn't rhyme.
Let's see, coming of age, 1995.
So sophomore year,
I think they gave us
our yearbooks way late.
Love the graphic design on this.
Well the graphic design on the 93
is horrible.
Looks like an oil spill.
It's like.
Looks like somebody
discovered fonts for the
first time and was like,
"Well, let's use all of them."
Yeah, not all there.
That's what we were.
What does it say on the back?
Not all there but
here's the best.
But here's the best.
Good God.
What does that mean?
I mean there's the, we weren't
on the yearbook committee
so we can't take credit
for that non sequitur.
Not all there but here's the best.
Coming of age.
This is a slightly better one.
Yeah this is tasteful.
Design-wise.
Yeah I wrote on the inside cover.
Link Neal will never come of age.
That is hilarious man.
That's true.
You wrote, "Lunar."
You've never called me Lunar,
it's a cute little nickname that ah.
Yeah.
Starts with an L
but you've never called
me that before or since.
That was just for this yearbook.
The yearbook was an opportunity for just,
to work out new material.
Well I was hoping you would come of age
and start using it as your moniker.
But this gets to kind of
your point of ambition.
"Lunar, coming soon to a theater near you.
"The Judge.
"The script is to be written.
"The life is to be lived."
Oh.
"The day is to come
"and we will be there.
"You will be there, I will be there.
"Let's get there."
Wow.
Rhett.
You signed it Rhett.
Wow.
You know what The Judge is?
I don't know man.
I'm sure it's awesome though.
It's a movie.
It's a movie idea that
I think you just made up
on the spot for the sake of saying.
Well, I didn't expound on it.
The script is to be written,
the life is to be lived.
Yeah.
We're gonna write a script
and then live it?
The day is to come.
Yeah man.
I think it's gonna write
a script and we're gonna live the life
of making the movie.
Well so.
We will be there.
You will be there, I will be there.
Let's get there.
Now this is what I wanted
to talk thank you about.
I love this.
Because there is a,
you know there is a scene
in "The Lost Causes of Bleak Creek"
and you may have figured out
that Rex and Lief are you know,
analogs to Rhett and Link.
And.
Yeah I did.
There's a scene in, in the book where
Rex is like getting Lief to think about
something in the future and
something that they're gonna do.
I think about how they're gonna meet.
They're gonna have breakfast
with Robert Zemeckis.
Yep.
And that was in the book
because it was very indicative
of the very big dreams
that I would bring into
our friendship and be like,
"Come on man, we're gonna
do something amazing."
Oh yeah.
And this is what,
and this is the plan.
We're gonna, in one point.
It was we're gonna to UNC Asheville.
I'm gonna play basketball there
because they've come to see me play
and they've written me some letters
and so they're kind of recruiting me.
Junior year.
And they have a film
school or a film minor,
I couldn't remember which one it was.
And so hey, we'll go to UNC at Asheville.
I'll play basketball, we'll major in film
and then we'll become filmmakers.
Yeah.
And so the thing I.
I was like, "Do they
have a soccer program?"
No I didn't, I did not care about soccer.
I never again.
I never, the way that I thought.
I just knew that you were
always gonna be into the idea.
Right, and so it wasn't
like ever was like,
"All right I gotta have this
conversation with Link."
It was more just like
it went without saying
that if I said this kind
of thing in your yearbook,
even though I'm kind of
just screwing around.
But like I'm.
We were having
these discussions.
Setting an intention
about the future.
In the cow pasture, the
discussions that led
to the blood oath which may.
I believe, like I don't know
when we dated the blood oath
in the past.
This had to be around
the same time.
But I have to.
If I had to put money on it,
I think that the blood oath is
around, after sophomore year.
Sometime in junior year.
Because that's when you're getting like,
that's when you're forming
this UNC Asheville plan.
You're like, "We're thinking about our."
You're thinking about your future.
Your parents are thinking
about your future.
The counselors are telling
us to apply to places.
That would've been between
junior and senior year
because I wouldn't have
been getting any interest.
I got interest.
Okay.
From them.
Well that's late,
that's late to do the blood oath.
No the blood oath was earlier.
What I'm saying is that,
I'm just saying the UNC Asheville idea
because I played AEU basketball
and had had a pretty good junior year.
So I wasn't getting college
letters after sophomore year.
Oh okay.
So that was when it was.
I think the blood oath
could've been that late then.
It could've been.
Maybe.
Junior, late junior year or
summer after junior year.
Is that when you did AAU?
Summer after or during junior year?
I did summer after sophomore
and summer after junior.
Okay, so in that realm.
So we were having this conversation.
So then yeah there wasn't,
The Judge is not a specific idea we had.
No.
But you made it very
specific in the yearbook
because that was just a choice you made.
But it was a reflection of,
like deep bloodletting conversations
that we were having in that cow pasture.
We never stopped going to the cow pasture
throughout high school.
We've been back too.
We did not outgrow that.
Yeah and if you want us.
In Good Mythical Morning,
we go back to Buies Creek
and we did a three or four episode series
where we literally take you to the places
that we're talking about.
So check that out.
But yeah I mean, you.
You orchestrated in your
mind this UNC Asheville plan.
It was a compromise to like, you know,
with your dad thinking about okay,
he's giving you so much opportunity
and you've capitalized on it
when it comes to basketball.
Well this pays that off.
But it also gets you into a film program
which is something that we wanted to do.
And then how did I respond to that?
I mean you said you knew
I would be on board.
I mean I think that's, that's
a dramatic understatement.
Because for me, you know, I
didn't even know how to engage
in the future.
I didn't know how to make plans.
I wasn't, you know my mom
wasn't having conversations
with me about like,
hey you can take this
thing you're interested in
and turn it into the rest of your life.
Like you were having those
basketball conversations
with your dad you know right?
So for me, and that's
just not really the way
that I think.
But I had this deeply
rooted feeling of like,
I mean, maybe it's even
attachment to our friendship.
You know so it's like,
I'm sure it wasn't my
idea to go to summer camp
back when we did that years earlier.
But I was like,
"Well if Rhett's gonna go, I'll go."
I still may hate it and be the one
that means we're not gonna go again.
But I, you know we're
hatching these ideas of like,
"Okay we can make.
"We make videos for presentations.
"We are funny, we're a duo."
Like that was our biggest
identity in high school
above these other things
we're talking about.
So for me, without knowing
the application of it
I was just like, this is.
I'm comfortable in this friendship.
I have, I have hopes.
I don't know that I had my own dreams.
I had my own hopes.
So I kind of felt like
when you brought the dream
and attached it to,
like my hope immediately paid off.
So it was like this huge relief.
I felt like as much as
you practice basketball
with your special shoes
and your blocks and like,
we couldn't go and swim in the river
until you had shot 100 basketball shots.
Maybe 300.
Like I would go over to your house
and just sit in your
yard and just be like,
"What the hell man?"
Yeah.
It's like hurry up dude.
It was just like, I was just
waiting on you to get done
so we could go chase cows.
So that dynamic was a play on
the macro scale too of like,
who am I to say, hey yeah
let's, let's hatch a plan
to be filmmakers.
You know, I've felt like I
was at the mercy of like,
this basketball plan.
So when you start saying things like,
we can do this.
We can do, I can do both
so that we can do this
and if I, because that's
what I really want to do.
We need to do something.
It's like you know,
making a blood oath for me
was such a validation of
my hopes and it was like,
oh this is official.
Rhett actually prioritizes
what we can do together
over this basketball thing.
Because you know, leading
up to that for years
it wasn't like, we didn't have
those type of conversations
about everything you know?
It wasn't, I'm sure there were many times
where there were like question
marks and it was like,
well I'm not gonna push this.
I'm also not one to like have
specific futuristic dreams.
So once you made it official with the oath
and then once you start
making these plans.
I'm like, yes, yes, yes.
It was like a relief to me.
Because it's just
something that I was hoping
that would come together
but I couldn't push.
And then when you come
back and you're like,
you know, once you realize
that's not gonna happen you know?
And the reason that, and
you know what happened.
We got very serious about
the band that summer.
That was when.
After junior year.
Yeah, so that was when you know,
towards the second half of junior year
and the summer before senior year is when
you're kind of in that timeframe
is when our music went from
singing like country covers,
two lead singers
with cowboy hats and white
t-shirts and jeans to like,
I'm gonna actually.
I'm gonna get a guitar, I'm
gonna learn how to play guitar
and write music.
Because I feel like we need to take this
in a certain direction.
We don't need to be playing
other people's songs.
We need to be writing our own music.
Yeah.
And I mean I always tell that story,
like I was embarrassed that
we had two lead singers
and so I started playing guitar.
That's the joke version.
The real version is is I was like,
we need to write our own music.
You know listen, if we're gonna be a band
we need to be defining some kind of style
or something right?
And it doesn't need to be The Eagles.
Right and so.
Which is what Benny
had written in the 70s.
And again I am, if I'm
really good at anything
it's drinking my own Kool-Aid right?
It's like I am great at making
and drinking my own Kool-Aid.
That's kind of what propels me.
I think I like it too apparently.
My gasoline is my Kool-Aid
and so once we start writing music,
by the time basketball
season rolls around,
I specifically remember thinking,
"Okay I'm gonna do this because you know,
"I have gotten to this point
"and I've done all this
work for basketball."
I'm gonna try to some extent but,
I'm not gonna play college basketball.
I had made a decision
before I even started
playing my senior year
that I wasn't gonna
play college basketball.
I wasn't telling my dad
that but I was kind of like,
"I'm gonna do well and I'm gonna shoot
"a hell of a lot of threes.
"But my future is as a rock musician."
You know what I'm saying?
That's what I was thinking.
Yeah we were both so aligned.
We were both so committed
to the band that it was,
and it was much more real right then
than being filmmakers.
Right.
So it eclipsed it.
And it wasn't like,
oh we'll never make videos again.
But it was like,
right now the thing we're
trying to break into
is this music industry and specifically
the Christian music industry at the time
in a very particular time and place.
So that's why that dream went away.
So I'm actually interested to see what,
I don't know if.
Well.
If this has anything,
the 96 yearbook.
Our senior year.
Has anything to do with that.
Yeah like the thing
that I've found here is
the senior, what's it called?
Like your last words
as a senior.
Your senior quote.
Senior quote, that's what it's called.
Now I would've, I'm not gonna.
I'm gonna guess that what I
would say in this situation
and what you would say in this situation
wasn't actually true.
But was more about what
are people going to think
when they read this?
Are they going to laugh?
Are they going to think
that we're weird or?
It was more about how
people would perceive it.
That's how I would've approached this.
So that's what I'm guessing
going in.
Yeah this is
a public statement so it has to be stupid.
This is not a personal mission statement.
"I Rhett McLaughlin leave
at the speed of a plunge
"from the 75-foot plunge
cliff with a pod at my side.
"Get 'em Dogz."
With a Z.
So do you want to, let me read mine
and then we can decide for both of them.
Let's see.
"I, Link Neal leave with
the boys pondering the pod.
"Acapulco, wax paper dogs
and various excursions."
We mentioned all exactly the same things.
"Knowing Harnett Central High School
"will catastrophically
crumble in our absence."
Catastrophically crumble in our absence.
Ah that's funny.
Which by the way,
that phrase, knowing that it
will catastrophically crumble
in our absence is totally something
that my son would write in his yearbook.
It's just like this fake bravado
that he just, I don't know.
That's his sense of humor.
Which son?
Lincoln.
Not Lando.
So Lake Acapulco was a lake in Lillington
that was an old rock quarry that had been,
where we would, you would break in
and you would jump the fence
and you would jump off of the cliff
which was actually probably 35 feet.
It was very tall but it wasn't 70 foot.
It's taller from the top.
It wasn't 75 feet but it probably 35 feet.
It was enough to, if you didn't land right
you'd get hurt.
Yeah so that's what you
called the plunge cliff
and I called Acapulco.
Yeah.
Yeah 'cause by senior year
that was the thing that we were,
we were instigating groups
going, jumping the fence.
And hopefully there would be
a full moon so you could see.
But I mean it was scary
jumping off of this cliff
because it was a swimming hole.
A lot of military people
would come up from Fort Bragg
and swim there and get drunk
and some of them would jump
off and a few people died.
Yeah.
So they closed it down
and it was never open, day or night.
It was abandoned.
I would love to go by there.
I know, it's so close to my nana's house.
But yeah, jumping off of
that cliff in the dark
was petrifying and if you hit wrong,
you could really get hurt and we,
we talked to all of our friends to.
Boys and girls to jump off of that thing.
It was terrifying.
It was very.
So it became
this rite of passage and of
course, we were the instigators.
And then everybody did it
because we made them do it.
Well there's a peer pressure you know?
Everyone gets a really hard
time if they don't do it.
Yeah it wasn't just us
but it was our idea.
So yeah we, I mean, I guess senior year.
That was like the big thing
that we were getting people to do.
So you were leaving at
the speed of a plunge
off of the Lake Acapulco
cliff with the pod at my side.
So that was the camping pod.
That was the group of guys
and occasionally girls
who would camp by the river.
We were very proud of that group.
Right.
We started letting them come out
and chase the cows with us
at night and camp with us.
It wouldn't just be the two
of us, it'd be a group of us.
That was fun.
I mean the fact that we
didn't go out there and drink.
I think most people probably expected
that that was gonna happen.
They expected but like.
So no, we're gonna like,
might drink some Coke.
That's not what we do.
Yeah if it was,
if some of our other
friends were in charge,
then they would have, then
we'd have been drinking.
I'll tell you, that would've been fun.
It could've been really dangerous though.
Yeah.
Especially crossing the river.
So I mean I'm glad we
didn't for our own safety
but yeah because we were in
charge we got to set the rules
and we were very pious because again,
the third piece of this when you're like,
"Get 'em Dogz."
It's like the wax paper dogs
was the biggest thing on our mind.
It wasn't like you're gonna see my film.
We didn't put that,
neither one of us put that
and we put the same thing.
We had really,
we really developed our
group of guy friends
and then our group of
guy and girl friends.
There was like.
And so the message
I wrote to you is not compelling here?
No, actually I don't, there's not one.
What?
You did not write
in my senior yearbook.
How is that possible?
I don't know man, I don't know.
Maybe it was just too pure.
Yeah you didn't write
in it, I'll look again.
I mean surely I did somewhere.
My girlfriend.
Whoa, that's tiny font man.
Well she wrote a lot, yeah.
I had learnt from this
that we'd been dating
for three months at the, when I graduated.
That's really late to
start a relationship.
Yeah, you should've
thought twice about that.
I didn't, you know.
So that's what.
That's why it was like, it
lasted through freshman year
because it had just
started senior year.
Yeah.
Like I came back and
went to prom with her.
Oh you did that.
Yes.
Oh college boy coming to prom.
Because she was a junior.
Yeah.
Like when I was a senior,
she was a sophomore so like.
So yeah that.
That was
a bit more acceptable at the time.
Just to throw that out there.
We're all very old.
Well I didn't.
Wow and here's
my good friend who was my
girlfriend and then my enemy.
Why did she stop?
She was leaving room for
somebody else to write something.
I guess.
Maybe me.
No you didn't, you did not.
Go to the front.
You did not write in my yearbook.
Maybe I wrote in the front.
No no no no, you didn't.
That's it.
What, this is sad.
You'll have to see if
I wrote in yours dude.
But yeah so it's not that big of a deal.
Well I mean I guess it can't
be 'cause I didn't have it.
Maybe I'll write in it now.
But we, you know we had
this group of friends.
First of all, talk about the prom.
You know we have that iconic prom photo
in my girlfriend's front yard
where we're shaking hands
and we got the one leg
lifted in the air.
Well I found these photos I took before
we went to my girlfriend's house.
My mom took pictures of just
me and you in my kitchen
and boy we're.
I mean we're doing the pointy fingers.
We're going to the prom.
I got tails.
But not together.
We do have dates.
Working your tails.
Oh it's me, you and the fridge.
Oh.
Me and you thinking
about how much fun the prom is gonna be.
This is just us getting ready
for meet and greets in the future.
We had to come up with
different ways to pose.
And here we, here we are shaking hands
but we did not lift the leg.
This is the precursor to the leg lift
and then there we are.
Just kind of styling a wide shot.
Total side note here,
when I started looking
back through these photos,
I was like,
"Oh man, I remember my kitchen."
You know it's like, the photo.
My momma's taking a photo of us
but I'm just looking around that kitchen.
It's like you never just take photos
of your childhood kitchen thinking
when you're a middle-aged man
it will trigger so many memories.
Like look at, I remember that
thin pantry.
I still haven't done
the thing that.
You know I talked about
this a couple years ago.
Taking that 360-degree camera.
I know, we need to do it.
And taking pictures of
the inside of the house
so my kids will always remember
what their rooms would look like.
But I gotta do that before
Locke goes off to college.
But if you look at,
this is when we were at
the graduation party.
At the Maranatha Cafe and
you just look at all these,
all of our friends and
like, you know, a lot.
A couple of them were dating.
I dated, you know some of
us had dated each other
and then broke up and still
stayed friends and like,
I miss these people man.
The last time we had a
reunion I wasn't able to go
'cause there was a hurricane.
Yeah I that.
It's like you go back home and like,
we really had a special friend
group where it was like,
some of them put up with our piety.
All of them put up with our
craziness and they were,
a lot of them were along for the ride
with our crazy ideas.
Like we're gonna cross this
river with everything we got
in trash bags.
And if you get swept down the
river, we'll come get you.
Just go to that bank,
not back where you came.
Because then you'll have to cross again.
That was the instructions.
And keep your feet in front
of you so you don't die.
They were petrified.
They weren't getting
them jumping off cliffs
but like going over there and camping.
You're just staring at this photo like,
are the memories flooding
back or something?
I'm just looking at everybody.
I mean and to think about, we are younger
than Lilli is now.
We're younger than Locke is now.
And I just think, I remember.
Well this is almost
the exact.
Same age as Locke.
This is the same age
as Locke, yeah.
And almost the same age
as Lincoln right now
and I just think.
I remember thinking about how much
I had figured out you know?
Really?
I just thought we were like,
I thought I was a fully functional human.
I was not.
Well yeah, I mean to say the least yeah.
Yeah I don't know exactly
what I'm thinking.
But we had a good
group of friends.
Because you know, yeah.
I'm very, in trying to
relate this to the dynamic
of our friendship.
It was such an interesting
thing because we were so,
we felt like there was.
And there was.
There was something special
between the two of us
that sort of eclipsed any other connection
we had with other people
and that had been,
that had begun to solidify
because of the dynamic
that I talked about earlier
about just kind of being on the same team
conceptually in the way that
we wanted to approach life
and deal with things.
And then for whatever reason,
and we explore this in
a different episode.
But we got so serious about our faith
and everything became
about the Great Commission.
It was like our lives are gonna be
Yeah we're gonna be in a band
but that is superseded by this idea
that we're doing it all
for the glory of God.
And because none of the other
guys in the group were like,
"Okay, I'm gonna go along with that."
I mean of course the guys in the band did
but they were in different grades.
They were, we were friends
with them through the band.
We just had this double whammy connection
because there was a conceptual
sort of stylistic connection.
Yeah yeah yeah.
But then there was
the worldview connection.
Me and you yeah.
So wrapping up high school
and getting ready to go into
college, there was just this,
and again, this wasn't
anything we processed.
You can only kind of
see this looking back.
There was a very unusual connection
that we were then taking into college.
'Cause we were also like,
"Oh we're gonna go to
college and room together
"and study the same thing essentially."
Oh yeah.
Ah we're gonna get,
to me there's this thing with twins right?
And you've got different types of twins.
But you've got the
twins who get to the end
of their high school and
they begin making decisions
about college and they're like,
"Well of course we're
gonna go to the same school
"and we're gonna have the same."
We knew twins like that.
We knew twins that you kind
of experienced in college.
But in twins, eventually,
sometimes they make a choice.
Sometimes they don't.
I mean there is a, thanks to the internet
I know about a set of twins
that married a set of twins
and they all live together.
It happens I guess.
Interesting possibilities
there.
But even for twins
that was a point, that's
a point where it could be
a point of separation.
That was never on the table for us.
Right, yeah.
It was like basically,
I was gonna go to college
wherever you were gonna go to college.
If basketball was a determining factor.
Right.
And then when it just
became about well you're good at math
and you're good at science.
So you should go into engineering
and that's true of both of us.
Yeah.
And Michael Jhube's parents
took us to visit State's campus
and we were close with Michael.
Yep.
And Trent was going to NC State.
Michael was going to NC State.
So it was like, and they
were part of our pod.
Don, he was going to NC State.
Nobody else from our friend
group was going to NC State.
But most of the dudes, so yeah.
Five of us.
Yeah.
So I'm actually surprised.
No, no Don went to DCU.
I think he thought he was going to State
and then maybe he switched up.
I think that's what happened
'cause he wrote a note in my yearbook
about going to State together.
Okay.
But I'm actually surprised
that we didn't stay closer
with Trent and Michael
but they were on the other side of campus.
And of course, we're not
gonna get into college.
Yeah yeah.
If we keep
this series going and maybe we should.
We always think we've
told all these stories
but looking at it through
the lens of our friendship,
I think it is a different dynamic there.
So it's like, we were bringing that,
this twin energy I guess
to follow your logic here
into our college career.
And, but yeah.
Looking back on high school.
It was, we had all these
different ways that we were.
I mean we didn't even talk
about the church aspect of it.
But yeah that's kind of
what the band grew out of.
Right.
So there's so many different
identity defining elements
of our high school career
that then were all pretty rewarding.
And our friendship group
was also a big part of that.
I think that's my takeaway is that like,
feeling a little sappy about
the friends we had back then.
We had a good friend group.
You know and,
and whenever we did.
Not everybody has that.
When I read the notes it's like to me,
it's like man you were so crazy.
Thanks for bringing so
much to our friend group
and to our friendship.
We weren't always on the best terms
but we always came back
together as friends.
Yeah.
I still love you.
All of the girls at some point,
there must have been a thing
because most of them
ended up saying to me.
You had a way of crossing all of them.
Blah blah blah blah blah,
but I still love you.
You know?
Yeah,
well that's not surprising.
I'm sure in their own way,
all Mythical team members can
feel the same way even now.
Yeah exactly.
Like ask Stevie, she's like,
"Ugh yeah Link but I still love him."
I think is how a lot of people feel.
You gotta dig up your yearbooks man.
I'll find them.
Don't stand on
the top ladder.
I'll find them.
I need to get a robot to help me.
So do you have a rec?
Oh yeah, let's go to the rec.
TikTok, I recommend
following ThisIsRangerKeith.
Have you seen this guy?
No.
He goes out into the woods
and it's almost meditative.
And he's like.
Hey, get out of your head.
Are you doing your best?
And are you being reasonable?
Oh that's not the one I want to show you.
Hey, it's Ranger Keith.
I'm out birding this morning
and I thought you might
wanna take a minute
to just wind down a little bit.
We're just gonna sit and
listen and be present.
If you don't know your
bird calls, that's okay.
I'll just tell you what they are as we go.
Pssht, oh there was a
blue-gray gnatcatcher.
Cheeseburger, cheeseburger,
cheeseburger down the hill.
It's a Carolina wren.
Carolina wren.
Northern parula we just got here.
Northern parula just got here.
Carolina wren again.
Northern parula again.
Peter peter peter.
Peter peter.
Tufted titmouse.
Angry squirrel.
All right, I'll see you later.
There you go.
Well I'm mesmerized.
This is Ranger Keith.
Is he in North Carolina?
I love you man, I don't know where he is.
He's with birds.
Well I mean.
Tufted titmouse.
I guess the Carolina wren
can migrate elsewhere but.
I love a tuft titmouse.
Not titmouse, whatever it is.
I don't know.
Well he's a very peaceful man.
Yeah, that's what you get
on TikTok if you want it.
Anything you want, yes.
Anything you want.
It's not dancing.
I mean it is dancing teenagers
but none of those come
up in my For You page so.
#EarBiscuits, thanks for
experiencing our friendship
with us again.
Yes.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits"
click on the playlist
on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits"
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.